what a historic night it was
at the big a as we welcome you to
the big a game two of this four game
series between the halos and texas
rangers on a beautiful
southern california saturday evening
and the tone is set by the man on the
mount right here tonight is andrew
hinney he's throwing the ball so well we
just talked about that what he's done
over his last
four starts going three or three and one
with the era and the twos he's got to
continue that especially going against
lance lynn and the rangers tonight
leonie tavares
leads off batting right to use him in
that lead off spot
and he hits his ball pretty solidly out
to center field
trout ranging back he's at the wall gone
a home run
leote tavares starts the game with a
bang tonight in la and now it'll bring
up rugnet odor
he needs first offering and that ball
well struck
deep out to right and that one is gone
wow and that was a no doubter odor
struck the pose immediately he knew and
in right field
walsh hardly gave it a look a two-run
shot
take a look at lance lin's 2020 season
and 11 starts as era
is all the way down at 2-4 with a whip
under one
bunch of strikeouts 79 only 23 walks and
opponents are hitting
only 176 against him well this guy
always a challenging opponent
trout goes after the 1-0 pitch got under
it a little bit
out to right field and paneled
by white for the final out of the inning
it's a one two three for lance lin
three nothing tahina goes down swinging
on the off speed pitch and there's the
first down in the second
math is hitting 170. down goes mathis at
a one two three second inning for heaney
good change up there to get a swinging
move
shohei oh johnny back in the lineup 189
five home runs and 20 runs pounded in
and that is ripped out to right field
eli white going back and that one
is off the side and gone big fly oh tony
son
that is his first since august 23rd
angels get on the board it's three to
one texas welcome back to the lineup for
shohei ohtani apostle at the plate
got him swinging two on and two stranded
three one texas as we head to the bottom
of the third they just haven't given him
a whole lot to work with he takes strike
three and goes down
looking to start the third inning he's
now one for 16 against the rangers this
year
eli white come back into the mound of
the second
foul tipped into the mid two down
swinging miss on a
four-seam fastball
ground ball to short simmons
retired jeff mathis and we'll head to
the bottom of the fourth inning angels
are down 3-1
man on it for albert pujols jared weaver
bouncer shortstop to hate it a second
one roogie's relay
in time double play it's leone who
stands in the box at fun
tavares goes down swinging to open up
the fifth inning fifth strike down now
for him
good breaking ball down and in here's
taylor ward
taylor ward shoots one out to right
center field that's going to get down
and go for extra bases
can run and he is going to score easily
all the way from first base as a throw
trickles into the middle part of the
infield
and the angels are down a run it's fun
watching shohei oh tiny run and another
good swing for
taylor ward going to right center
fletcher's
really really good season with runners
and scoring position
fletcher punches one to right center
field and that'll tie the score up at
three
upper third don't even try it against
fletch
and with the runner and scoring position
back combo for lance lindell tied at
three
adore down goes odor one out
he's over two having grounded out struck
down
he'll go down swinging two down
back-to-back strikeouts
right through two really good change-ups
to him
two out here in the seventh inning
that's drilled down towards center field
trout's got to go back on it boy some
carrying to the warning track
trout makes the catch for the third out
stretch time here at the big a we're
tied at three
ward had an rbi double in the fifth
inning
the o2 and he strikes out
ward one away sassy who has
struck out both times he's been in and
that is strike three called and he's
gotten stassi for the third time
all three times looking so drought who
is hitless tonight opportunity put the
angels on top
pull the left side connor falefa can't
handle it it gets
by him and fletcher scores to give the
angels a 4-3 lead
another rbi for trout versus the rangers
109 now in his career
joey gallo 186 batting average one two
for myers
breaking ball got him looking down goes
galil light that baby up
as the angels pick up the victory
tonight by the final of four to three